[What's one interview question
you ask every prospective employee?]
I guess, actually, one question
that always comes up is,
"What, specifically, did you do?"
In other words, people
will come to you and say,
"Oh, I did this project.
I did this, that and the other thing."
And you're like, "OK, that's nice,
but what, specifically, did you do?"
Because a lot of things are team efforts
and it can be very vague.
You know, I asked somebody,
"What did you do
in this 3D world analysis?"
Because there were many parts of it.
And then I would ask, you know,
"What, specifically, did you do?"
And the answer to that
just greatly clarifies
what their skill set is.
It could have been any number of things
in the system that she had done,
and then when I know exactly what she did,
then I have a better insight into that.
Also, from the interview
and the way they answer the question,
you maybe not specifically ask,
but you listen for a passion
and an interest in what they do.
If they're just answering
in one-word answers,
and they seem bored by your questions
or defensive,
that's not a good sign.
But if they say, "Oh, well,
I use Microsoft Visual Studio
and I'm using C#
and I really enjoy this language,
because it's this, that
and the other thing, and it's better,
I used to use Java, but now I use this.
I love Visual Studio
because it allows me to integrate."
And they go on and tell me,
or seem passionate about it.
And the answer doesn't have to be,
"I love Microsoft."
It could be, "Well, I use
Eclipse, I love Eclipse,
and I love Java, I love Open Source.
I love Open Source because this,
and I'm very passionate and I always use
Ubuntu and I love Linux so much!"
If you hear that,
if you hear how engaged
they are in what they do,
and that they love what they do,
if they come with a vital energy --
that's very attractive in an employee,
because that shows someone
who's going to engage and learn
and, you know, just add a lot
of energy to your team,
and that's what, I think,
a lot of employers are looking for.
(Video) Click any of these fortune cookies
to see your questions
and follow-up questions explored.
Click this cookie to return
to the intro video
and see what this series is all about.
Or click this cookie
to suggest alternative questions,
participants, or career paths
for future videos.